well you're intelligent guy with very
reasonable points you deserve all the
credit that you've gotten but you are
also honest like your these are your
actual opinions and this is your actual
perspective the real problem with
someone like Ann Coulter or someone like
many of these other people that I see
out there that you we don't even have to
name is it they're hustlers yeah they
found an inn you know yes there's an inn
for a certain type of conservative
person there's an inn for a certain type
of democratic persons and then for a
certain there's Pro women people that
don't give a [ __ ] about women they're
[ __ ] absolutely you know the
absolute supposed feminists when they're
just narcissists there's a lot of that
out there there's men's rights activists
that really only care about finding this
way into a group of people where if you
have their support there's just a large
conglomeration of them and you can sort
of take them in as your fans do you feel
a knit do you feel like that died down a
little bit the men's rights activist
thing yeah yeah I feel like there were
maybe three years ago it was very big
and then I have read about it yeah you
got [ __ ] from them right didn't it what
what [ __ ] you know having them be upset
at me I don't give a [ __ ] but my bit was
that every men's rights activist I ever
met I just want to grab and go dude we
got them all shut the [ __ ] up we run
everything what's their almost
everything the whole idea is that not
that I don't think men should have
rights but it's just we've got them yeah
and that my thing in the bit was what if
women started pay attention to things
men actually did when they started going
hey we just realized you guys caused all
the war every single war ever and like
if you mention if women caused all the
war whoa we gotta kill these [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] all you want to do is go
to war this was in your most recent bag
right yeah that's great
and they thought out there was some of
them that were upsetting me but like
that's a pretty bulletproof argument
like right the only men's rights are
argument this legitimate is divorce laws
sure I agree with that and we're in when
it comes to alimony and when it comes to
child support and when it comes to child
custody yeah they're totally agree with
that there are men they get [ __ ] over
and I know guys that have gotten [ __ ]
over in that regard
and you know what courts tend to side
towards the mother and if the mothers
deceptive and if the mother is you know
they'll say something like he beats the
kids or I think he might have done
something sexual to the kids yeah these
women have done horrible things like
that and they've done that to get more
money or they've done that to get
custody or they've done that just for
spite but this is just this is a matter
of the courts being designed to protect
this situation a system being designed
to protect kids and protect the mother
who needs to get money to be able to
take care of the children because
there's a lot of [ __ ] shitty deadbeat
dads now if there were no deadbeat dads
if men always pay child support then
this would be far less of an issue yeah
the issue exists the reason why women
can exploit it is because so many men
were pieces of [ __ ] sure it created this
need for some sort of some sort of law
that said something something that's
said to protect children and to protect
women with with that get custody yeah
and now it looks like the do with the
divorce issue and everything the
pendulum swung a little too far in the
other direction
and there's like this default setting
which is actually not too good for the
guy right and I know you're talking
about - because I saw that podcast a
long time ago I think it was one of the
people he worked with on Newsradio or
something that's just one of them that's
just one of them I know many people that
have been [ __ ] over by divorce but and
you know and look I have a good friend
of mine who I've talked about him on the
podcast before he has been divorced for
14 years he has been married to a new
woman for 12 years he still pays alimony
not only does he still pay alimony he
pays alimony to tune of more than
$100,000 a year to a woman that he
doesn't have sex with so he can't retire
he cannot retire this woman has a
boyfriend she lives in his old house in
my friend's old house she owns the house
and they don't have any children this is
the idea that he [ __ ] her so hard she
can't work again like she's not 80 years
old man I mean she's now in her 50s
that's almost like indentured servitude
it's [ __ ] insane but you'd like to
give me $100,000 in life he's giving
well it's it's tapered down to like I
think it's now
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year but if one point he was paying her
a quarter million dollars a year and
he's paid or that for 12 [ __ ] or 14
[ __ ] years now 14 years he's been
married to a new woman for 12 he has a
family he has a family and asked to send
money to this lady he doesn't talk to
anymore like she can't move on with her
life and if he doesn't he gets locked up
if he doesn't he goes did you tell ya I
mean this is and he's trying to go to
court and she fights it and she lives
with her boyfriend and when they send
people over to check the boyfriend puts
his stuff in a [ __ ] new hall drives
around the block waits and then comes
back so what if let's say let's say he
loses his job and he can't find another
job for whatever reason he just always
the money no matter what and there's no
be like you can't go back in front of a
court and they can read you know take it
down or whatever that's good question I
mean you'd have to go to court and the
judge would have to agree but he's a
successful man that's part of the
problem is he's not going to be a loser
he's an ambitious guy he does really
well he works very hard he works 1012
hours every day and he has forever and
he's good he's smart he's good at his
job and because of this he has to pay
this woman that he doesn't [ __ ] anymore
forever that's crazy man it's a nice
lazy it's a nightmare
but here's the thing it's like she's not
she's not like she's not in a hospital
bed it's not like she can work
it's like she's she's totally capable of
making a living and she now has probably
four or five plastic surgeries she's the
person we were talking about earlier I
don't even know maybe she went she fits
the route maybe she went the opposite I
don't know but the idea that my friend
has to pay her and every now and then
you know we'll talk about I'm like you
still have to pay her I just go oh my
goodness he's [ __ ] I mean he's got a
family he's got a wife and he has
children with this new woman and he's
happy and he still has to pay what is
that two thousand dollars a week two
thousand plus a that's just an absolute
nightmare hilarious so here's a check
for $2,000 lady I don't even know
anymore